all right y'all let's finish up with
something we came across on social media
this is what I'm
[Music]
liking an attorney turned pasta maker
that's right that's what I said is
sharing his secrets to creating some of
the most colorful and interesting
noodles ever he makes everything from
ravioli to lasagna soup all from scratch
I know check out Tik tok's Danny loves
pasta last year my lasagna suit videos
got almost 100 million views and now
that the weather is getting colder it's
time to bring back lasagna soup is
basically a deconstructed lasagna and if
you remember we call this the siza
lasagna
soup water that post combined got over a
100 million views so people are into
lasagna soup is what we have figured out
now Danny has a book out called Danny
loves pasta and we have him on the line
watching on NBC New York what's up
Danny thanks for having me well thank
you for joining us so how does one go um
from lawyer to Pasta
expert well pasta has always been my
favorite food and when I was growing up
my grandmother was this amazing Italian
American cook and she would make these
huge feasts and I'm kind of embarrassed
to say this but I was a very picky eater
so I would always only eat the pasta she
would make and she would always make
fresh pasta for Christmas so in 2020 my
husband and I had just had a newborn
baby so we couldn't go home for
Christmas so I was like I'm going to
learn how to make fresh pasta I made her
fresh FR pasta I called her she loved it
um but unfortunately shortly after
Christmas my grandmother very
unexpectedly passed away and it was very
very hard on me I had been so close with
her um so I just kept making pasta in
her memory to try and keep her memory
alive and to feel close with her um and
it kind of just snowballed from there
very
unexpectedly oh that's so beautiful so
how did you get so good at it just
practice uh practice practice practice I
started with her recipes and then I sort
of took it in a different direction I
use all natural ingredients like spinach
and beets and turmeric make a pasta in
every color of the rainbow uh now we
have a three-year-old daughter and a
three-month-old daughter so uh my older
daughter likes to be in the kitchen with
me so I'm always making shapes for her I
make pasta uh that looks like her
favorite cartoon characters or flowers
or plants or unicorns or rainbow so
hopefully one day she'll be making pasta
in the kitchen with me oh that's so cool
man that's so cool you're doing this the
time you're spending with her but also
teaching her how to like really cook
herself meal I wish I knew how to really
do that um but I can postmate so um
everybody thank you so much for joining
us this is so cool and it's so beautiful
that you're carrying on your grandma's
Legacy everybody pick up Danny's book
Danny loves pasta wherever you get your
books thank you so much Danny I'm liking
your post right now
right all right and that's not all our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
G2 the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarks and
show want to honor truly Unstoppable
people just like you man so they're
going to be riding you a check for
$1,000 how's that sound thank
you thank you Danny and thank you to all
our guests this hour Jennifer Garner
Tony Gonzalez Billy de Michelle and
Victor y'all have a great day and if
it's not try and change
[Music]
me
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home